it's an interesting question how did the
Peace the Abraham Accords how did that
begin
you know I mean we had you know we had
decades but 70 years where they or 65
years where these people you know would
not uh
meet openly when it or even secretly
with an Israeli leader yeah we had the
the Mossad making contacts with them all
the time and so on but how do we break
the ice to the top level of leadership
well we broke the ice because I took a
very strong stance against Iran
and the Gulf States understood that Iran
is a formidable danger to them so we had
a common interest and the second thing
is that because of the economic reforms
that we had produced in Israel Israel
became a technological Powerhouse and
that could help their Nations not only
in terms of anything just bettering the
life of their peoples
and the combination of the uh
of the desire to have
some kind of uh protection against Iran
or some kind of cooperation against Iran
and civilian economic cooperation uh
came to a head when I gave a speech in
the American Congress
uh which I didn't do lightheartedly I
had to decide to challenge a sitting
American president and uh on the the
so-called Iranian deal uh which I
thought would pave Iran's path with gold
to Be an Effective nuclear power that's
what would happen uh
so I went there
and in the course of giving that speech
before the joint session of Congress
our delegation received calls from Gulf
States
who said we can't believe what your
prime minister is doing he's challenging
you know the president of the United
States well I had no choice I mean
because I thought my country's own
existence was imperiled and remember we
always understand through changing
administrations that America
under no matter what leadership is
always the Irreplaceable and
indispensable Ally of Israel and who
always remain that we can have arguments
as we have uh but in the families we say
you know it's the the family but
nevertheless I was forced to take a
stand that produced
calls from Gulf States that ultimately
led to clandestine meetings that
ultimately flowered into the the Abraham
Accords then and I think we're at a
point where the idea of ending the
arab-israeli conflict not the
palestinian-israeli conflict the
arab-israeli conflict can happen I'm not
sure it will it depends on quite a few
things but it could happen and if it
happens it might open up the ending of
the Israeli Islamic conflict remember
the Arab world is a small part
it's an important part but it's there
are large Islamic populations and could
bring about uh an end to the historic
enmity between Islam and Judaism it
could be a great thing so I'm looking at
this larger thing though you know you
can you can be hobbled by saying oh well
you know you've had this uh you know
this hiccup in Gaza or you know this uh
this or that thing happening in the in
the Palestinians I don't it's important
for us because we want security but I
think the larger question is can we
break out into a much wider piece and
ultimately come back and make the uh the
peace between Israel and the
Palestinians rather than waiting to
solve that uh and and never getting to
the the uh to paint on the larger canvas
I I want to paint on the larger canvas
and come back to the palestinian-israeli
conflict